I mentioned to you Offline that I uh
desperately in trying to figure out the
optimal in an ordered set questions to
ask you I texted Eric Weinstein asking
for what questions he can ask you and he
said that you are
definitively one of the greatest living
mathematicians so don't screw this up
but you did give me a few questions
um so he asked uh to ask you what are
the most shockingly passionate this is
in Eric's language what are the most
shockingly passionate mathematical
structures and he gave a list of four
for him but he said he really wanted
your list okay let me say that
shockingly passionate mathematical
structures shocking
okay is there something you can uh is
there something that jumps to mind sure
I'm here to shock yeah
so first of all Eric Weinstein is a is a
very dear friend I have to say and I
really really appreciate and love him uh
he's just like my brother so you know
it's it's interesting to um
don't have a question posed by him maybe
if we can linger for a moment what do
you think is special about Eric
Weinstein for you know of his work and
his mind
the way he sort of straddles so many
different disciplines it's like a
renaissance man there are very few
people like that at any given moment let
alone the 21st century where information
has become so
you know huge that it's almost
physically impossible to be able to keep
track of things and yet
he does and he has his own unique vision
and unique point of view and he has
integrity
which is like almost impossible like I
can't think of so many people who
possess that those qualities almost no
one
and also the
the ability
in some sense to um to embody the
balance that you talked about
of both the rigor of mathematics and the
uh the imagination Humanity also I would
say you know like we talk about
imagination
um as a kind of a Counterpoint to
knowledge or logic but just basic
Humanity you know just be basic just
compassion just being able to
because
um
every destructive I would say like every
destructive
um Society you know like be it Germany
you know and Hitler or Soviet Union
under Stalin and so on
it was based on some kind of what was
considered unassailable truths so a kind
of conceptual system you know if you
think about it right there is a
beautiful episode of this
um series by um Jacob bronowsky you know
um where he talks about he filmed it in
Auschwitz
talking about the certainty that what
led the Nazis to be killing people
wholesale was a certain it was almost a
mathematical idea
and they just basically bought into this
idea and checked out their Humanity at
the door
so I would say that antidote to this
type of thing is not necessarily even
imagination in a kind of elevated sense
that we have been discussing today uh
that is exemplified by by our greatest
um scientists
and philosophers
but just basic Humanity you know basic
human basic common sense of just like
knowing that it's just not right and I
don't care what my see what my ideology
tells me but I'm just not going to do it
so
that I think is kind of missing a little
bit in today's society because people
get a lot too caught up in in the
ideology in in certain conceptual
Frameworks so societies that lose that
basic human compassion the basic
Humanity around the trouble
oh very much so but not only Society
like a human being and uh Eric is one of
the people I agree with you
keeps that flame of you like I trust
that he will not do something
that's not human that's not right
I just feel that you know like there's
some some people you just kind of feel
that they won't cross that line yeah and
that's a huge thing you know today
because I have to say looking back
definitely
I have not heard people personally but
like I could be mean for instance I
could be harsh
and now I see it as a sign of weakness
as a sign of insecurity
you know I saw I saw your interview with
Rick Roswell the other day
it's beautiful I was really moved by it
but you know that at some point I was
like
I I looked at him at this sort of like
Dr Evil
I'm kind of ashamed of it now but like
you know I'm kind of kind of clean
and I would you know
because well why because I needed an
adverse adversary in my mind because I
projected onto him kind of the fears
that I had that we will be the AI Will
Conquer us and so on
and this was rooted in my
kind of Awakening moment in a sense a
kind of a moment where I suddenly
started to see the other side so but I
wasn't sure yet
you see you have to feel it so I had to
have a fight about it yeah you had to
actually have the projection I had to
that so it was not in I I believe that
it was not in me already so I had to
throw it onto somebody yeah
and that's not balanced yet so balance
is when you recognize that it's you
actually so and I had this moment
actually it was so amazing like I would
give this mean I would talk about Ai and
the dangers and he would always be my
like um foil you know I would put a
Sinister photograph of it okay on the
slide and it's like look at this guy he
wants to put Nanobots into your brain
and he's also like high-end High a top
executive at Google and so on like so I
would create this whole narrative
and then something happened
uh where I was giving a lecture this is
2015 at the in in Aspen Aspen ideas
Festival which is a wonderful Festival
so keynote speech actually and I and I
was doing my my usual stick and then
suddenly I said
I came up to that uh on it was a big
screen and there was a picture of him
there and I came up to the screen and I
kind of touched it with my hand and I
said but
I don't want to pick on Mr Kosovo
because he's me I had this Revelation
that I'm actually fighting with myself
with my own fears
and and then I learned about
his
um his um his father that his father
died when he was young
and that he's in fact he's very
um to his credit he's very um sincere an
upfront about it self-disclosure I think
it's very Essential by the way in all
this discussion like what really
motivates you
he said it he said it publicly many
times even as early as 2015 I could find
this information
that he wanted to reunite with his
father in the cloud and suddenly I saw
him not as a gray caricature
that exemplified all my fears but as a
human being who a child longing for his
father grieving for his father
so suddenly it became a story a love
story
and you know
so that is so in other words I've seen
it in myself
this
capacity to
project my own fears and then fight with
other people over something that
actually was my own
and as soon as I got to this point of
seeing him and then my next lecture
actually I talked about it about him in
this way
and I and I said look you know it's a
love story and he is actually
um
it's not how I would want to reunite
with my father uh
but like you said you know that if I am
consistent I have to allow the
possibility that different people
um
perceive things differently and so for
him
that's his imagination so you know how
who is this well Voltaire I think is
ascribed to Voltaire she's like I
disagree with you but I will fight to
death for you to have the right to say
yeah so now that I I feel like my
position is more like I disagree with
him that this is the way to
to approach death and to approach the
death of loved our loved ones and how we
miss them and how we
you know that sense of loneliness and
inability to interact directly
that
that's not something that is nice with
me
but I think it's also it can also be
called imagination from his perspective
and look motivated by that
how much he has brought
how many interesting inventions like his
in musical invest for instance naturally
because his father was a composer a
music composer and a conductor
so in other words from in the bigger
scheme of things
even if I think he's misguided
still I can't deny that it will certain
leap of faith from his perspective to
try to say that this is the way we can
all connect to our loved ones and
because it is sincere and I see it now
sincere and in fact in your interview
you really teased it out of human it was
I was really moved by it I have to say
it's like he has smelled a little bit
twice
it was really really sweet when he
talked about his father and I can relate
you know my father died four years ago
and I can relate what a heartbreak I was
much older than Ray was when his father
died but I can relate to this
um to this longing and that grief you
know and when he is somebody sincere and
he puts his
opens his cards and you know
and says this is why that's what I want
to do it because I want to recreate my
father and I want to be able to talk to
him this way
then we have a series then we understand
you know the opposite of it would be not
this closing
and just
um
pretending that this is how it's
supposed to be in a scientific term so
freedom is replacing the real emotion
but come from the Heart by some kind of
a theory which comes from the mind and
this is where we can go astray because
then we get become captives of
Frameworks and conceptual systems which
may not be beneficial to our society in
tough times we need the people that have
not lost their way in the ideologies we
need the people who are still in touch
with their heart and you you mentioned
this with Eric is certainly true I
disagree with them on a lot of stuff but
I feel like when the world is burning
down Eric is one of the people that's
you can still count on to have a heart
I've talked a lot over the past year
about the war in Ukraine and the
possibility of nuclear war and it feels
like he's one of the people I would call
First
um
if uh if God forbid something like a
nuclear war will begin because you you
look for people with a heart no matter
their ideas that's right it takes
courage and it takes a certain
self-awareness I would say and which
brings I mean you know I think the
crucial is that that which was inscribed
you know on the Temple of a Poland
Delphia it was a statement No No thyself
not yourself you know the who am I
ultimately it goes down to this and all
these debates and the point is that it's
like I used to be like I said you know
pessimistic at some point and I was
scared even of where development of AI
was going this is about 2014 2015.
and now I'm much more
so for instance after I saw Ray
courtswell as a human being after I
could relate to him
and sympathize
with him suddenly
I I stopped seeing him in the news like
before that I would always see him in
the news saying we're going to put
Nanobots in your brain by the year 2030
or whatever you know and then we upload
you to the 20 by the 21st and I will be
like no you know the story was terrible
suddenly I didn't see him anymore
I had to you know so now it makes me
question who was creating the trouble
what was all with it was it him who's
creating stirring the trouble or was it
my mind you see and so as I become as I
became self-aware
suddenly other possibilities opened and
suddenly that conflict which by the way
if I kept giving this
nasty you know talks about him one one
day that I suppose we'd have a debate
and so you have this
um one person says this and then yeah
and what I learned is that it never it's
a never-ending con this conflict just
does not end
but there is an alternative there is a
better way
which is to realize that it is you
arguing with yourself
now if you want to continue arguing with
yourself
continue as long as you need
just be careful not to destroy too many
things you know in the process but there
is an option of actually dropping it of
actually dropping it this is so I was so
surprised by this
yeah it's discovering in yourself the
capacity the human capacity for
compassion and you understand that
he has a perspective he is operating in
the space of imagination a human being
like you and we're all in this kind of
together
ultimately and also it's like with
realizing how much
I have screwed up you know comes with
humility also yeah so like I find it
extremely hard now to like really Lush
out at somebody and to say like you're
horrible whatever because immediately
question is
who am I to criticize you know so is
there another way to have a dialogue is
there a way to you know speaking you
know since we talked about
um the innocence of a child and how much
it drives a discovery in science and so
on you know I remember I think it was I
think I heard the Ashanti who gave this
nice example he's like when you're a kid
you know you go and you you play with
your friends and then you fight with
another kid and he was like I hate you I
don't want to see you again and you just
go home like after half an hour okay
what are you gonna do you want to play
so you come out it's like hey you want
to play you don't talk about what
happened you don't rehash this you know
let's keep going and sometimes I think
we are on the verge maybe of learning
that
because I think that if we are can if we
continue to push
each of us our set of ideas and like
ideologies and like
you know what matters to us and so on
like yeah no no what matters to you but
like there are other ways to approach
other people there are other ways you
can find point of contact
speaking of which mathematics
mythical formulas
are Universal represent Universal
knowledge two plus two is four whether
you vote for this guy or that guy in the
election you know how about that as a as
a point of of contact of commonality you
know and nobody can patent those
formulas did you know that there is a
Supreme Court decision that mathematical
formulas cannot be patented like
Einstein could not patent equal E equals
m c squared
it doesn't belong to him because if the
formal is correct
then it belongs to everyone
so what do you think of that all too
tricky question and if you want I can
deeply bias your answer by giving the
list of four that Eric provided oh no
let me give my mind I cannot see by the
way what you have yes so but I can guess
some of them
so I'm going to try to do something
different from him so I already
mentioned one which is that you have one
dimensional
um in the medical system which is real
numbers you have two dimensional which
is complex numbers you have four
dimensional and it's kind of it's
probably connected to what he wrote
Because has to do with some homotopic
groups of spheres and stuff like that
then of course the one I love okay one
plus two plus three plus four plus five
plus six and so on
does it make any sense the sum I mean
you probably heard about this one it
became a very popular at some point one
plus two plus three I did I did a video
for number file the the YouTube channel
about it maybe 10 years ago so one plus
two plus three plus four plus five
ostensibly
uh diverges goes to Infinity because you
got a bigger and bigger number and yet
there is a way to make sense of it
in which it it comes up to -1 over 12.
how fascinating first of all the answer
is not even a positive number and it's
not an integer it's not a whole number
it's minus one over twelve so sometimes
people ask me what is your favorite
number
and it's a kind of a joke I say minus
one over twelve
it's actually 42.
so your favorite number is not an
ordered set
uh right so what else what else uh so
language program of course I have to
mention that and we'll we'll explore
that in depth do you want do you want do
you know what Eric said sure sphere
aversion
boys surface hop vibration vibration
okay and
Pi 1 of SO3 okay oh yes so that's the
that's the famous cup trick you know
okay look so this is how it works
no tricks no tricks no matter honest it
is magical okay
not because I'm tricking you so you
start with a a bottle like this or a cup
and you start twisting it at the same
time you twist your your arm then you
come so this is actually going to
um rotate at 360 Degrees the full turn
then you say okay I won't be able to do
another turn because then my arm would
really get twisted I'll have to go see a
doctor yet if I do it second time it
untwists
this is the by one of SO3 Eric is
talking about yes so there is something
where
the first motion is not trivial but if
you double down on it you come back to
the initial position
it's a very closely connected to the
fact that we have Elementary particles
of two types bosons and fermines
so bosons are for example photons or
carriers of other forces or the Higgs
boson it is called a boson for a reason
because it is a Boson uh in in honor of
Indian mathematician Bose b-o-s-e and
Einstein so this particles obey what's
called Bose Einstein statistics but then
there are other particles called
fermions
in honor of Enrico Fermi Italian foreign
mathematician who worked in in the U.S
and and they follow what's called Iraq
Fermi statistics and those are electrons
and constituents of matter electrons
protons neutrons and so on and they have
a certain duplicity if you will and that
duplicity is rooted mathematically in
this in this experiment this little
experiment that they have just done
so I can I imagine speaking of
imagination okay yeah so I'm just kind
of briefing on this imagine a world in
which this will not be shocking or like
in this case it's not even shocking
because I haven't really explained the
details because I can't do it in two
minutes I I indicated
what this is all about and so on but
imagine a world in which this is not
foreign to most people that most people
have seen it before or they're not
afraid to approach this type of
questions because you know we talked a
little bit about Mass education but I
really believe that a lot of people in
our society and it is not not only in
the United States but throughout the
world a lot of people have been
traumatized
it's really PTSD that's why people when
they see mathematical formula or lake
even like how they need to calculate tip
on the bill they it's just they're
terrified because it brings up those
memories when they were kids and being
called to Blackboard
and
solve the problem you can't solve a
problem and ask groupless teacher says
you're an idiot sit down and you feel
ashamed and and then lowly and that
stays with you and so I think that
unfortunately that's where we are
dream and so my dream is that one day
we'll be able to overcome this
and actually all of these Treasures of
mathematics
will become widely widely available or
at least people will know where to find
them
and they will not be afraid of going
there and looking and I think this will
help because like I said for one thing
it gives you a sense of belonging it
gives you it kind of is an antidote to
the kind of alienation and separation
that we feel today oftentimes because of
ideological divide
sectarian strife and all kinds of things
like that because then you will once you
see there's a critical mass of this
beauty
that kind of like tones on you is like
my God this is what we all have in
common